welcome back I'm Steve Brenton and today
I'm gonna tell you about the Laplace
transform which is one of my absolute
favorite transformations at all of
mathematics the Laplace transform so
many of you have heard about the Fourier
transform I just did a whole lecture
series on the Fourier transform the fast
Fourier transform and I kind of think of
the Laplace transform as the culmination
of all of the the work on Fourier
transform so Laplace in some sense
generalized the Fourier transform to a
much larger more important class of
functions that you can now transform ok
so I'm gonna tell you all about that
right now
I'm gonna walk you through how to derive
the Fourier transform from the Fourier
transform and then how to use it to do
things like compute derivatives and
solve equations and I'll point out you
know in in math usually there's no
there's no magic wand but Laplace
transform is about as close as it gets
you can take a system and subtract about
2 or 3 years of advanced math from how
hard it is to solve that system just by
applying the Laplace transform so for
example if you have a partial
differential equation a PDE under
certain circumstances you can Laplace
transform it and turn it from a PDE into
an OD e which is much simpler similarly
you can take an OD e and under some
conditions you can transform it with the
Laplace transform into an algebraic
equation which again this goes from
college to high school kind of solution
techniques and the Laplace transform is
also extremely useful in control theory
so the Laplace transform is going to
crop up all over the place and today I'm
going to derive it for you and show you
how it's not actually separate from the
Fourier transform it is in some sense a
generalized Fourier transform okay so
many of you have seen the Laplace
transform and Fourier transform for
years and you've noticed similarities
today I'm going to show you how they are
exactly the same thing the Laplace
transform comes from the Fourier
transform so
the plus is one of my absolute favorite
French mathematicians he was the son of
a peasant farmer and went on to have his
name on the Eiffel Tower that's one of
the things I love about the French is
that they Revere their great thinkers
and mathematicians and scientists and
the plaza was truly one of the greatest
fun fact about Laplace he was one of the
first researchers ever to realize that
when you're dealing with real-world data
which has noise and isn't perfect you
have to look at that data through a
probabilistic lens through the lens of
probability theory for us we take that
for granted but that was a huge deal
back when the plos lived in the second
half of the 1700s and the early 1800s
okay so let's jump in the big idea here
is that we we know that we can Fourier
transform nice well-behaved functions
that decay to zero at plus and minus
infinity so I'm just going to draw an
example of that if I have this nice
Gaussian that goes to zero as X or T
goes to plus or minus infinity I can
Fourier transforms I'm going to say
Fourier transform check we can do the
Fourier transform but less well-behaved
functions so there are nastier functions
out there and I'm gonna draw a couple of
them right now like e to the lambda T
this function you can't Fourier
transform because it does not go to 0 as
T goes to 2 plus infinity so you cannot
Fourier transform this function another
example of a function that is tricky or
impossible to Fourier transform is the
Heaviside function I really like this
Heaviside function that is 0 for
negative time and 1 for positive time so
let's be explicit and call this time and
this is the Heaviside function named
after oliver heaviside and it's 0 for T
less than 0 and it's 1 for T greater
than or equal to 0 this function also
you can't easily Fourier transform
because it doesn't taper off to 0 at
plus infinity ok now there are other
examples where technically you can
Fourier transform it's just a little bit
of a pain
so let's think about this trigonometric
function now again this doesn't decay to
zero at plus and minus infinity but
there are tricks you can play so the
most common trick is to multiply this by
a window function W where basically W is
1 on some window and 0 everywhere else
so now if I multiply W by my sine
function or cosine function it does have
this nice property and then I can take
the limit as this window becomes
infinitely large that's one way you can
Fourier transform these signals but
again it's kind of a pain so what I'm
gonna show you is how the Laplace
transform is basically a weighted
one-sided Fourier transform for these
nasty functions okay that's that's all
I'm gonna show you today and then we're
gonna use it later on ok good and you
know this all is due to pierre-simon
laplace one of the great great
mathematicians so the solution and make
sure I can actually write where you can
see so the solution is let's call these
our little functions f of T ok these
little functions f of T so our solution
is to multiply f of t by some very
stable e to the minus gamma t e to the
minus gamma t that's an exponential
function e to the minus gamma t so that
f of t e to the minus gamma T goes to 0
as T goes to positive infinity
ok so only as T goes to positive
infinity so the first thing we're gonna
do the solution is we're going to take
our function f it's badly behaved and
we're gonna multiply it by a decaying
exponential function so we're gonna
multiply it by a decaying exponential so
that when those multiplied together it
will go to 0 for as T goes to positive
infinity now you might be thinking well
we solved this problem in the positive T
infinity direction but now my function
might blow up at negative T infinity T
equals negative infinity so we don't
just multiply by e to the minus gamma T
we also multiply by our handy Heaviside
function H of T ok so now what we have
is we're going to define this big
function big f of T is going to equal a
little F times e to the minus gamma T
times Heaviside of T
all right that's that's what we're gonna
do we're gonna take our badly behaved
little F of T and we're going to
multiply it by a sufficiently stable
exponential e to the minus gamma T where
if I multiply them it goes to 0 at t
infinity and my Heaviside function so
that what I get is something that is
zero for T less than zero that handles
this thing blowing up at negative
infinity and it equals F of T e to the
minus gamma T for T greater than or
equal to zero good so this this is the
whole the whole thing we take our badly
behaved function we multiply it by a
stable exponential and a Heaviside
function and now we're gonna Fourier
transform big F so the Laplace transform
of little F is the Fourier transform of
big F good and I'm gonna write this down
over here I'm actually going to box it
so my I'm gonna write down my Laplace
transform pair just like we write down
our Fourier transform pair so we're
gonna have f of T it's going to equal
some Laplace transform it's re inverse
Laplace transform and F bar of s is
going to equal my my Laplace transform
ok good so I'm just going to save these
and we're gonna fill these out later so
the Fourier transform of big F is going
to be we're gonna call that big f hat
and it's going to be a function of Omega
and that's going to equal the integral
from minus infinity to infinity of big f
of T e to the minus I Omega T DT this is
what we always do when we Fourier
transform that's the Fourier transform a
big F and remember I can Fourier
transform big F because I've multiplied
it by the stable Gaussian and the
Heaviside function so it
zero at plus or minus infinity so I can
for you transform big s okay and now
what I'm going to do is I'm just gonna
substitute in my my formula right here
for this big F the first thing I'm going
to notice is that this Heaviside
function is 0 for all T less than 0 so I
can change the bounds of integral of my
integral from instead of minus infinity
to infinity its 0 to infinity so now
this is from 0 to infinity and I can
drop my Heaviside function of little F
of T e to the minus gamma t e to the
minus I Omega T DT ok so I've changed my
bounds of integration because of my
heavy side function so instead of
negative infinity to infinity I'm doing
0 to infinity and then what I'm gonna do
is I'm going to group these
Exponential's here and I'm gonna say
that this equals integral from 0 to
infinity little F of T e to the minus
gamma plus I Omega T DT and the last
thing I'm gonna do is I'm gonna say that
gamma plus I Omega is my Laplace
variable s that's a pretty bad bracket
so I'm gonna say s equals gamma plus I
Omega
that's my Laplace variable and so this
equals integral 0 to infinity f of t e
to the S T DT and that is my Laplace
transform the Fourier transform of big F
is my Laplace transform of little F
that's the definition of the Laplace
transform it's the the Laplace transform
the Laplace transform is the Fourier
transform of a one-sided weighted
function f it's a one-sided waited for a
transform I think of it as a political
Fourier transform ok good and so I'm
just literally gonna say that is defined
this is f bar of s that's how I'm
defining f bar of s sorry it got cut off
a little bit f bar of s equals the
integral from 0 to infinity of little f
of T
e to the minus s T DT that is the
definition of a Laplace transform and
now the inverse Laplace transform is
just the inverse Fourier transform of
this big f hat of Omega ok so that's
what I'm going to do now and maybe I'll
do a different color here so now what
we're gonna do is we're gonna say big f
of T is the inverse Laplace transform of
this and if I remember correctly that's
1 over 2 pi integral negative infinity
to infinity of F hat Omega e to the now
instead of minus I Omega T it's plus I
Omega T and we're integrating with
respect to D Omega ok good and this f of
T was little F times e to the minus
gamma T remember I want a little F of T
out for my inverse Laplace transform so
I'm going to take this and I'm going to
multiply both sides by e to the plus
gamma T so e to the plus gamma t e to
the plus gamma T and that's going to
give me the little f of T that I want
out so little F of T equals this
weighted inverse Fourier transform of
big F Omega and now I'm just gonna start
working through what the mass here looks
like ok so this equals and remember that
F hat Omega is the same as f bar of s
these are the the Laplace transform
little F bar is the same as big f hat
and so this is going to equal 1 over 2
pi integral minus infinity to infinity
I'm gonna just swap this out and call
this f bar of s and now my e to the
gamma t times e to the I Omega T is e to
the gamma plus I Omega T D Omega ok good
and you'll recognize this is our handy
Laplace variable s so now all I have to
do is I have to change this D Omega and
the bounds of my integration to a d s
and I'm just going to do that right now
for you so if I look at D s remember
gamma is just a constant it's
a constant that's big enough that this
goes to zero so gamma is a constant so
des is I times D Omega okay good and
that means that D Omega is just 1 over I
DS and so I'm just going to swap out my
D Omega for 1 over I D s ok so this is
I'm gonna put my eye out here in my in
my coefficient 1 over 2 pi I think I'm
gonna run out of space here so I'm going
to do it down here so this is 1 over 2
pi I integral of f bar of s e to the
positive s TDS ok and here's the last
last last thing is that if Omega went
from minus infinity to plus infinity if
Omega went from minus infinity to plus
infinity then s goes from gamma minus I
infinity gamma minus i infinity to gamma
plus I infinity ok so that is so my
bounds of integration changed and that
is the inverse Laplace transform that's
all that there is to it so now F of T is
just 1 over 2 pi 2 pi integral gamma
minus I infinity to gamma plus I
infinity F bar of s e to the positive st
D s and this should look very much like
the Fourier transform parrot because it
is a Fourier transform here the Laplace
transform pair if I have some function
of time F of T u it's badly behaved I
can take its Laplace transform this way
and if I have the Laplace transform F
Bar of s I can inverse Laplace transform
and recover my function f of T my
original function and this works for
nasty poorly behaved functions that you
could not normally take the Fourier
transform of ok so let's take a step
back the Laplace transform is a
generalized Fourier transform for badly
behaved functions so instead of just
directly Fourier transforming those
badly behaved functions what we do is we
multiply them by a stable exponential so
that they decay to 0
and a Heaviside function so that they
don't blow up at negative infinity and
then we Fourier transform that product
so this is a one-sided because of the
Heaviside function weighted because of
the e to the minus gamma t fourier
transform so it's a it's a one-sided
waited for a transform for badly behaved
functions that's all the little applause
transform is and it is extremely useful
because lots of the solutions of PD ES
and OD es and control theory look more
like this and this and this then our
nicely behaved functions where we can
easily Fourier transform so in the next
lecture what I'm going to do is I'm
going to walk you through some of the
properties of the Laplace transform it
inherits most of the same properties as
the Fourier transform for example how
you transform derivatives or
convolutions and we're going to use
those properties of the Laplace
transform to simplify our PDE s to
Odie's ro d east algebraic equations and
we're also going to use this a lot in
the control theory bootcamp all right
thank you